Louisville Police Department has fired a
detective involved in the killing of
Brianna Taylor Taylor as you know was
shot eight times in March when officers
conducting a drug raid burst into her
apartment the suspect they wanted was
not there and no drugs were found on the
premises
Taylor's boyfriend opened fire because
he said he thought it was a burglary the
Louisville Police Department says when
Detective Brett Hankinson fired 10 shots
blindly he displayed an extreme
indifference to the value of human life
they say two other officers remain on
administrative assignment
Hankinson was fired the same day that
Rashard Brooks was laid to rest in
Atlanta
Brooks was shot and killed by police
earlier this month family and friends
joined politicians entertainers and
civil rights leaders for his funeral at
the historic urban easer Baptist Church
Jeffrey gazes in Atlanta with more on
this story
Rashard Brooks was remembered on Tuesday
as a father who cared deeply about his
family
Rachelle Gooden is his mother-in-law I
look at my grandbaby right there she's
looking she looks just like him and when
I look at her I know that he's not gone
Brooks his wife wiped away tears so did
many of those watching and listening
outside Rashard Brooks his life matters
Ernie's King the youngest daughter of
Martin Luther King jr. spoke about the
ongoing struggle for justice just as her
father did from the same pulpit 60 years
ago don't stop until it matters that
dignity justice and equity are reality
for all black lives
Rashard Brooks death will not be in vain
because justice will roll down like
waters and righteousness like a mighty
stream
it's been 12 days since Brooks was shot
and killed by Atlanta police officer
Garrett Roth the investigation which is
Unknowing has turned into a fierce
battle between district attorney Paul
Howard and defense attorneys for the two
officers the attorneys say Howard rushed
to judgment in charging the officers
yesterday he rejected that criticism
outside the church I
understand why people don't think that
you can look at a videotape eight of
them and decipher what has happened and
we were able to do that and Lana officer
Devon Brosnan is adamant that he did
nothing wrong that night
meantime separately the state
legislature has passed hate crimes
legislation it now goes to the
governor's desk he is expected to sign
it did you know that Georgia is one of
four states around the country that does
not have hate crimes laws gale I did
know that because I watch CBS this
morning so this is a very big deal Jeff
that this is now heading to the
governor's desk for signature thank you
very much